our ability to create and sustain
economic growth is the defining
challenge of our time of course there
are the challenges healthcare disease
burdens and pandemics environmental
challenges and of course radicalized
terrorism however to the extent that we
can actually solve the economic growth
challenge it will take us a long way to
solving the challenges that I've just
elucidated more importantly unless and
until we solve economic growth and
create a sustainable long term economic
growth will be unable to address the
seemingly intractable challenges that
continue to pervade the globe today
whether it's healthcare education or
economic development the fundamental
question is this how are we going to
create economic growth in advanced and
developed economies like the United
States and across Europe at the time
when they continue to struggle to create
economic growth after the financial
crisis they continue to underperform and
to see an erosion in the three key
drivers of economic growth capital labor
and productivity in particular these
developed economies continue to see
debts and deficits the decline and
erosion of both the quality and quantity
of labor and they also say productivity
stalling in a similar vein how are we
going to create economic growth in the
emerging markets where 90% of the
world's population lives and where on
average 70% of the population is under
the age of 25 in these countries it is
essential that they grow at a minimum of
7% a year in order to put a dent in
poverty and to double per capita income
one generation and yet today the largest
emerging economies countries with at
least 50 million people continue to
struggle to reach that 7% magic mark
worse than that countries like India
Russia South Africa Brazil and even
China are falling below that 7% number
and in many cases actually regressing
economic growth matters with economic
growth countries and societies enter
into a virtuous cycle of upward mobility
opportunity and improved living
standards without growth countries
contract and atrophy not just in the
annals of economic statistics but also
in the meaning of life and how lives are
lived economic growth matters powerfully
for the individual with growth wanes the
risk to human progress and the risk of
political and social instability Rises
and societies become dimmer coarser and
smaller the context matters and
countries and emerging markets do not
need to grow at the same rates of
developed countries now I know some of
you in this room find this to be a risky
proposition there are some people here
who will turn around and feel be quite
disillusioned by what's happened around
the world and basically ascribe that to
economic growth you worry about the
overpopulation of the planet and looking
at the UN recent statistics and
projections that the world will have 11
billion people on the planet before
plateaus and 2100 you're concerned about
what that does to natural resources
arable land potable water energy and
minerals you're also concerned about the
degradation of the environment and you
worry about how man embodied in a
corporate globalist has become greedy
and corrupt but I'm here to tell you
today that economic growth has been the
backbone of changes moving and
standards of millions of people around
the world and more importantly it's not
just economic growth that has been
driven by capitalism the definition of
capitalism very simply put is that the
factors of production such as trade and
industry capital and labor are left in
the hands of the private sector and not
the state it's really essential here
that we understand that fundamentally
the critique is not for economic growth
per se but what has happened to
capitalism and to the extent that we
need to create economic growth over the
long term we're going to have to pursue
it with a better form of economic stance
economic growth needs capitalism but it
needs it to work properly and as I
mentioned a moment ago the core of the
capitalist system has been defined by
private actors and even this however is
a very simplistic dichotomy capitalism
good non capitalism bad when in
practical experience capitalism is much
more of a spectrum we have countries
such as China which have practiced more
state capitalism and we have countries
like the United States which are more
market capitalist our efforts to
critique the capitalist system however
have tended to focus on countries like
China that are in fact not blatantly
market capitalism however there is a
real reason and real concern for us to
now focus our attentions on pure forms
of capitalism particularly those
embodied by the United States this is
really important because these type of
capitalism has increasingly been
afforded the critique that it is now
fostering corruption and worse still
it's increasing income inequality the
idea that there few are benefiting at
the expense of the many the two really
critical questions that we need to
address is how can we fix capitalism so
that it can help create economic growth
at the same time can help to address
social ills in order to think about that
framing we have to ask ourselves how
does capitalism work today
very simplistically capitalism is set on
the basis of an individual utility
Maximizer a selfish individual who goes
after what he or she wants and only
after they have maximized their utility
do they then decide it's important to
provide support to other social
contracts of course in this system
government do tax and they use part of
the revenues to fund social programs
recognizing that government's role is
not just regulation but also to be
arbiter of social goods but nevertheless
this framework this two-stage framework
is the basis from which we must not
start to think about how we can improve
the capitalist model I would argue that
there are two sides to this challenge
first of all we can draw on the
right-wing policies to see what could be
beneficial for us to think about how we
can improve capitalism in particular
right-leaning policies have tended to
focus on things like conditional
transfers where we pay and reward people
for doing the things that we actually
think can help enhance economic growth
for example sending children to school
and parents could earn money for that or
getting their children inoculated or and
immunized parents could get paid for
doing that now quite apart from the
debate on whether or not we should be
paying people to do what we think they
should do anyway the fact of the matter
is that pay-for-performance has actually
yielded some positive results in places
like Mexico in Brazil and also in pilot
programs in New York but there are also
benefits and significant changes
underway on left-leaning policies
arguments that government should expand
its role and responsibilities so that
it's not so narrowly defined and that
government should be much more of an
arbiter of the factors of production I
become commonplace with the success of
China but also we've started to
have debates about how the role of the
private sector should move away from
just being a profit motive and really be
more engaged in the delivery of social
programs things like the corporate
social responsibility programs albeit
small and scale are moving that right
direction of course also left-leaning
policies have tended to blur the lines
between government NGOs and private
sector two very good examples of this or
the 19th century the United States when
the infrastructure rollout was really
about public-private partnerships more
recently of course the advent of the
Internet has also proved them to the
world that public and private can work
together for the betterment of society
my fundamental message to you is this we
cannot continue to try and solve the
world economic growth challenges by
being dogmatic and being unnecessarily
ideological in order to create
sustainable long-term economic growth
and solve the challenges and social ills
that continue to plague the world today
we're going to have to be more
broad-minded about what might work
ultimately we have to recognize that
ideology is the enemy of growth thank
you
I want to ask a couple of pressures down
visa because one could react to your
last sentence by saying growth is also
an ideologies possibly the dominant
ideology of our our times what do you
say to those who react that way well I
think that that's completely legitimate
and I think that we are already having
that discussion there's a lot of work
going on around happiness and other
metrics being used for measuring
people's success and improvements in
living standards and so I think that we
should be open to what could deliver
improvements in people's living
standards and continue to reduce poverty
around the world
so you're basically pleading for
rehabilitating growth but the only way
for that to happen without compromising
the capacity of the earth to you know
take us on a long journey is for
economic growth somehow to decouple from
the underlying use of resources do you
see that happening
well I think that I'm more optimistic
about human ability and ingenuity I
think if we start to constrain ourselves
using the finite scarce and depleting
resources that we know today we could
get quite negative and quite concerned
about the way the world is however we've
seen the Club of Rome we've seen
previous claims that the world would be
running out of resources and it's not to
argue that those things are not valid
but I think with ingenuity we could see
desalination I think we could reinvest
in energy so that we can actually get
better outcomes and so in that sense I'm
much more optimistic about what humans
can do I think the strikes me about your
proposals for for rehabilitating growth
and and taking a different direction is
that you're kind of suggesting to fix
capitalism with more capitalism with you
know putting a price tag on good
behavior as incentive or developing a
bigger role for business in social
issues is that what you're suggesting
I'm suggesting we have to be open minded
I think it is absolutely the case that
traditional models of economic growth
are not working the way we would like
them to and I think it is no accident
that today the largest economy in the
world the United States has democracy
liberal democracy as its core political
stance and it has free-market capitalism
to the extent that it is free free
market capitalism as its economic stance
the second largest economy is China it
has deep prioritized democracy and it
has stay
capitalism which is a completely
different model these two countries
completely different political models
and completely different economic models
and yet they have the same income
inequality number measured as a Gini
coefficient I think those are the
debates we should have because it's not
app it's not clear at all
what model we should be adopting and I
think there needs to be much more
discourse and much more humility about
what we know and what we don't know one
last question that the cop21 is going on
in in Paris if you could send a tweet to
all the heads of state and head of
delegations there what would you say
again I would be very much about being
open-minded as you are aware the issues
around the environmental concerns have
been on the agenda for many times now it
was in Copenhagen 72 in Stockholm and we
keep revisiting these issues partly
because there is not a fundamental
agreement in fact there's a schism
between what they developed countries
believe and want and what emerging
market countries want emerging market
countries need to continue to create
economic growth so that we don't have
political uncertainty in those countries
developed countries recognize that they
have a real important responsibility not
only just to manage their co2 emissions
and some of the degradation that they're
contributing to the world but also as
trendsetters in R&D and so they have to
come to the table as well but in essence
it cannot be a situation where with me
start ascribing policies to the emerging
markets without developed countries
themselves also taking quite a swipe at
what they're doing them in both and
demand and supply in developing markets
the B's I thank you for coming - thank
you very much